[Applause]
the pope discussing the existence of god
with an out-and-out atheist
starts off very correctly discussion
and as the hours go by it gets more and
more heated and eventually the pope
turns to the man and he said da mom
get the mom and you come here
you are like a man who is totally
blindfolded
in a dark room looking for a black a cat
that is not there
all respect your holiness i think
there's great similarity between us both
so what do you mean similarity you said
well as far as i am concerned
you are like a man who is blindfolded in
a totally dark room looking for a black
cat
that isn't there the only difference is
that you found it
i'm not religious i don't know if
there's a god that's all i can say
honestly is i don't know some people
think that they know that there isn't
that's a weird thing to think you can
know
yeah there's no god are you sure yeah no
there's no god
how do you know because i didn't see him
how do you
there's a vast universe you can see for
about a hundred yards when there's not a
building in the way how could you
possibly
did you look everywhere did you look in
the downstairs bathroom where
do you look so far no i didn't see them
yet i haven't seen 12 years a slave yet
it doesn't mean it doesn't exist
i just stopped waiting until he comes
uncapable
i think if there is a god i don't know
if it's the one in the bible cause
that's a weird story
is he's our father and we're his
children
that's it our father who art in heaven
where's our mother what happened to our
mom
what did he do to our mom
something happened somewhere in heaven
there's a porch with a dead lady under
it and i want this story
somebody's got to check the trunk of
god's car
for bleach and rope and fibers
well how can we not have a mother at
least maybe god's divorce
maybe he has an ex-wife god's a single
dad and he's raising us alone
and we're praying like hey and he's like
i'm trying it's just me
up here but i said the characters you
feel that the
new comedy there's so much atheists i
feel that's kind of like the new hack
comedy to me it's always been that way i
don't i'm not a proponent i mean i've
studied religion
in college and i take my kids that's
where i got into physics the the chances
of this thing happening
like by accident is carbon-based life
forms
but heavy stars deuteronomy you get into
the quantum physics
it's very peculiar that we're here at
all yeah church was never i got kicked
out of more churches
because of stupid crap i'd say yeah even
the bishop said we just don't want you
around here anymore
i mean literally well don't you find
sometimes the problems with
atheism is that really their problems
they're with churches
well listen they go there's no god
because a priest
i used to be quite religious and i'm
fascinated by lots of religious groups
there's
some brilliant ones there's the um the
people that wear the armbands wwjd
stands for what would jesus do and
christians wear them to remind them to
be more like christ in everyday life
they sort of see that oh what would
jesus do in this situation
for the most part they're very effective
they make people so annoying you want to
nail them to a cross
i became an atheist when i was 15 years
old i remember there was an exact moment
i was digging a hole with a stick and
now if you've just recently become an
atheist try to be cool about it
right because especially in this country
people use atheism almost like its own
religion
right because when you become an atheist
you're very angry because you you've
been fed so many lies that you become
angry
right so try to be what i call a good
atheist i used to be a bad atheist
right i like for example i didn't go to
a friend's wedding once because in a
church because i wouldn't set foot in a
church right
and then like i couldn't go to parties
because i always end up in a corner with
a christian going you're a [ __ ] idiot
right
and that's no way to live your life you
know
so you know what you got to live and let
live in this world
have the magic man don't have the magic
man
i don't give a [ __ ] and since i have
this new sunny disposition
my life's really turned around i've got
more friends i tolerate others i am now
godfather the three children and that's
[ __ ]
because these people know me and they
still
[ __ ] ass they still come up and go
jim will you be the child's godfather
and i'm like
yes and then i stand there in church
with the priests and the parents and the
priest is holding the baby and the
priest turns to me and goes jim
will you spiritually guide this child
throughout its life
sure
because i have no problems lying in
church
what difference does it make now there
are two reasons why babies are
christened
right there's the real reason which is
the church are trying to recruit people
who can't talk
then there's a second reason the bible's
reasons god's reason this is why
god wants you to christen your child
because if you don't christen your child
and it dies in infancy it doesn't get
into heaven
so if you are religious your god sounds
like a super guy
but if he lets one dead baby into heaven
then he has to let all the dead babies
into heaven
and before you know it heaven's just
filled with [ __ ] dead babies
won't be able to move for dead babies
and let's not act like these babies
didn't know what they did
now it's not
lost in me then when i tell a joke like
that in front of this many people
then in this room there's a good chance
there's a couple who lost their child in
infancy and i'm a comedian i'm meant to
make you laugh
and and i've just reminded you the most
horrible thing
that ever happened to you and for that i
am sorry
but if you weren't smart enough to get a
pedophile and a dress to put a small
amount of water on the child's forehead
what the [ __ ] did you think was gonna
happen right
as far as i'm concerned you're bad
parents
and that's why god took your child away
from you
because i think we all know that god
makes no mistakes
okay bill how do i tell my wife i'm an
atheist
bill i have the greatest wife in the
world and we have two wonderful
daughters
this is starting off like a horror movie
you know what i mean how it's always
like nice there's always like leaves
falling in a gazebo
but there's just that hint of creepy
music nobody used to do that back in the
80s when they
couldn't just depend on special effects
they actually had to build suspense
that's how this is look at this guy he
has a great is great he is the greatest
wife in the world everybody
and he has two wonderful daughters uh
there's a problem though she is a devout
christian
all right dude why are you acting like
you just met her you [ __ ] married her
and he goes and i finally decided that i
don't believe in any of it oh that's why
oh well dude welcome to enlightenment
you know you can't throw it all out the
window but you know the seven deadly
sins
the ten commandments all that [ __ ] makes
sense but all that other stuff you know
burning bush
talking to a bat that's walking on a
[ __ ] lake i mean come on
i mean are we adults here or what you
know
you have to throw your first baby over a
cliff to show that you love me
hey i was just [ __ ] with you you
passed the tell what the what is that
booming voice coming from the clouds
you know i just don't buy it
something's coming back like for the
love of god what what is it waiting for
you know what i mean is jesus like
thurman thomas trying to find his
[ __ ] helmet
during the super bowl is that was that
what's going on here um
that's two thurman thomas references two
weeks in a row you find another [ __ ]
podcast that does it three weeks in a
row and goddammit you should stop
listening to this one
um anyways he says i finally decided
that i don't believe in any of it
i thought about telling her the old joke
we're both atheist
i just believe in one less god than you
do uh but she wouldn't
find that funny at all she is okay she
she's
she is okay for now going to church
without me because i work nights but
i have a feeling that when the kids get
a little older
that i will have to become more involved
should i
tell her now or just let it be and hope
that it never comes up
well i have to tell you sir if you do in
fact
have the greatest wife in the world
she'll accept you for who you are
and if you're an atheist and you don't
believe
in the stuff that she believes in
then you know there you go this is what
i would do
let her let her take him to church
i i don't know what to do you know be
funny what if you took up needlepoint
okay and when you went to church you
just did needlepoint with your legs
crossed in the most effeminate way
possible maybe that's the way you do it
like some passive aggressive way
that you so embarrassed the most
wonderful wife in the world that she
asks you not to come
you know what if you do like a
needlepoint that just
is like little atheistic sayings and you
make pillows
and when they have like the church drive
like the bake sale and they wash your
car you sell
you sell the pillows that you sow during
the mess
oh you know what and they say jesus is
lord
but it's almost like like one of those
pink floyd songs that if you if you play
it
i don't know if you listen to something
like hidden messages or something or
or maybe they never did maybe just these
jesus freaks did that's that'll really
freak them out
it may have like subtle messages in like
the the outskirts of the pillow
about this is all a bunch of [ __ ]
and uh you don't believe in pedophilia
you know
no jesus that'll give me some [ __ ]
emails um anyways what did he ask should
i tell her now or just let it be and
hope that it never comes up
um you're basically saying should i
should i man up and be who i am or
should i stick my head in the sand
okay that's that those are your two
options so i i'm going to throw this
back at you sir what kind of man do you
want to be
do you want to be the kind of man that
sticks his head in the [ __ ] sand when
there's a confrontation
or you want to be that guy that just
sits down and just says listen
sweetheart
i tried i just don't i don't believe it
okay and i think it's great that you
believe it
if you want to go down there and sing
the songs shake some hands
close your eyes right make a pledge for
jesus whatever the hell you want to do
you go down there and you do that
all right it's like watching football i
like doing it you know
you know you're not into it you know i
don't i don't make you watch football do
i
i don't do that you know why because i'm
the greatest husband in the world
let's try that just ask her
listen wait does she know
she always she knows that you're not
going
ah jesus you know what you might want to
give her a little jesus juice
and uh get a little liquored up i don't
want to you know what dude
you got you got to tell her
you know i don't like how you're
deliberately working i feel like you're
deliberately working late on sundays
or early on sundays whenever the hell
she goes so you so you can just avoid
this you're avoiding [ __ ] sir
and this is a snowball all right
a snowball of jesus and it's rolling
right down towards you and at some point
it's gonna roll over you you know and
there's gonna be some [ __ ] creep
in church like that priest on the
[ __ ] sopranos that's gonna come over
and [ __ ] hold your hand when you're
out there doing the
your little job there all right so i say
you just tell her
just say i just look just be don't be a
douche just say i totally respect i mean
i'm [ __ ] around because i gotta make
this [ __ ] funny i don't care if you
believe in that [ __ ] god bless you
you know you know what i hope you're
right so you can laugh at me
um we all die um
that's how really i'm going to hell for
the rest of my [ __ ] for the rest of my
life you don't think that's a little
overkill
i think the rockefeller laws are [ __ ]
bad anyways um yeah just say look i
respect that you're into that type of
stuff and
listen you know what dude who gives a
[ __ ] somebody took you to church
somebody took you to church and you
after a while
realized that you didn't believe in it
so if she wants to take the kids to
church
just let her take him to church but your
wife has to be okay with the fact that
they say
yeah help them you all go down and pray
to the hippie
you can say because i don't believe in
that stuff i don't think it happened
okay in a couple of years you'll
understand what i mean
when i tell you about old saint nick
when i tell you the real story
you know there you go